le jour n'est pas encore levé et déjà
les premiers blancs des russes sont en
route vers donetsk est lougansk la
veille vladimir poutine a reconnu
l'indépendance de ces régions
séparatistes de l'est de l'ukraine et a
ordonné dans la foulée le déploiement de
ce qu'il appelle une force de maintien
de la paix
l'armée russe a franchi la frontière des
républiques de donetsk est lougansk à la
projection dans le nord et l'est de ces
réfugiés la russie se positionne dans
les régions séparatistes de l'ukraine et
pour le président volodymyr zelensky il
est clair que son homologue russe à
d'autres objectifs en tête
nous pensons qu'il s'agit d'un pas vers
l'escaladent la part de la russie
nous comprenons qu avec cette agression
la russie créé la base légale pour une
nouvelle agression militaire contre max
m
le président ukrainien envisage
désormais de rompre les relations
diplomatiques avec la russie il a
rappelé son chargé d'affaires à moscou
la voie du dialogue semble s'éloigner et
à kiev les habitants ne cachent pas leur
inquiétude
guerre ou pas guerre je ne sais pas mais
tout le monde a peur
le danger existe on ne sait pas ce qu'il
ya dans la tête de tout in
vladimir poutine n'a communiqué aucun
détail sur le déploiement des troupes
russes dans les régions séparatistes de
l'ukraine mais plus de cent cinquante
mille hommes sont déjà en place depuis
plusieurs semaines le long de la
frontière ukrainienne